I'm Dr. Fielder
My goal is to heal your mind
and reintegrate you into society
as soon as possible
I'm not insane
Stay calm
Wait no
No
Don’t move
You’re making a mistake
After 18 months
Today's the big day
18 months?
Are you okay, Stephen?
I saved you from years in prison
Baby
You really don't remember a thing do you Stephen?
No
Nothing
Doctor said one every morning
I'm fine
Something's not right
Father
Please go now
I just got this awful feeling
It's all coming back
I'm not the person that I thought I was
I want to know exactly what's going on
You're mistaking dreams for memories
These aren't dreams
You’re not making any sense
I feel like I'm caught
I’m here
But I'm not here
It's a sick experiment
The doctor said this might happen
I'm not going to hurt you, Stephen
Maybe it's time to call the doctor
How long we've been friends?
I honestly can't even remember
Well, that's right
I’m innocent
My mind was never yours
You remember what we want you to remember
I know what they’re doing here
Wake up
Close your eyes and relax
We'll get started